[Music]
hey i'm in chicago
here at the irish american heritage
center this was an elementary school but
then they shut it down
and now instead of learning to read and
write the children are learning the
valuable art of dancing without moving
their arms
i'm here with maureen o'looney
a
young italian woman who works here is it
a thrill to meet me am i much uh taller
and better looking in person well the
height of you to start with is something
that i didn't expect because senior and
television you're smaller
i'm much smaller well tvs are smaller
than humans
that might account for some of it uh i'm
going to learn irish step dancing today
oh dale's today well you're in the right
spot and i'll be honest with you i don't
have much of a backside no you don't
well you don't need that for dancing the
legs is the most particular thing you do
need a backside to keep the legs from
attached toe to the back and this is
what holds it in there you haven't
enough i haven't you have enough you'll
pass okay okay i didn't realize you were
studying me that closely yeah down there
you keep your eyes up i'm up here
okay it's my business not yours yeah
um
we are entering the irish gift shop now
here at the irish american heritage
center the soda bread oh soda bread
yellow we have the irish version of
bread and the scones not very good bacon
harrington's high risk oh bacon and
winston bread it's not as good as other
bread irish soda bread yeah whole wheat
bread it's good for your sister it's
good for your system that's what they
always say when you're eating something
that's not tasty look at this these are
tastes
look at that yeah potatoes
just in case you mistakenly pronounce it
potato they correct you no it's a taste
potatoes
potatoes
as we go down here we have the dancing
shoes here okay these are the shoes yeah
these are uh what does this these are
these are hardened pipe shoes these are
the shoes lizzie borden was wearing when
she
killed her family what is this that you
what is this saw the black stone turf
from ireland oh how much for this this
piece of turf from ireland yeah watch
this
paid top
top penny for this yeah that's a special
bit of turkey it's called black stone
turmeric oh you are running the greatest
[Laughter]
are you sure this isn't irish bread no
no this is kind of looks the same
it tastes like no no you can have the
chip instead
this goes well with a tea tree
[Music]
irish chef sauce right there
that's good that's the irish chef right
there he looks irish
check that guy out that's an irishman
how is he the irish chef
he's from mongolia look at this guy
that's not a leprechaun
that's a burn victim look at this gun
extra box is a tanto
[Music]
when the irish american heritage center
purchased this school the first thing
they did was they ripped out the library
and installed this block
this is kindergarten through third grade
right over here
there's a second bar
and there's this bar on the second floor
and don't forget this third floor bar
and just across the hall from the third
floor bar
this
portable bar on wheels
in case you can't get up this can be
brought to you in any location
and i'm sorry i almost forgot
the fourth floor bar
count them up that is
six bars
in one former elementary school
[Applause]
we're here for the great moment this is
where icon and o'brien learn
the uh art of irish step dancing you are
your name is shannon shannon deirdre
deidra conan
this is great this is terrific let's
compare arm freckles yes
all good all right in cartoons the irish
jig is always you know this is what i
kind of think it is
i mean i don't know what this do you
know what i mean
when i think of a guy finding gold at
the end of the rainbow i always say like
[Music]
laughing at me
this is what it was like for me as a boy
in fourth grade
so the feet one foot goes this way the
other one tuck it in behind them this
goes back that way yeah yeah okay knees
in now there's lots of tearing and
bleeding back here now is that normal
yes okay my arms squeezing my body
i'm standing very still
and now you have to hold that hold this
and move your legs and then and then
dance while doing this yes
it's impossible it can't be done put
your arms up see if they just float up
can we give me heavy things to hold i
mean what can we do
the first thing is a jump
right kick out then kick out then back
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well i'm feeling pretty confident about
my step dancing i think it's time for a
real performance
could i get one more two more
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
here they are the trinity irish dancers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the trinity irish dancers
ladies and gentlemen
let's please
let's please have a big hand for the
beautiful young woman i kicked in the
face
aaron gratis aaron
[Applause]